Hunter Biden he's back in the news and
not for his world-renowned artwork now
tonight the president's 53-year-old son
is attempting to dodge what is a house
subpoena now Hunter's lawyers say that
their client is willing to only appear
for a public hearing before the House of
Representatives not a closed door
deposition as the law requires now if
you or I would receive a subpoena from
Congress we would be forced to comply or
we would be facing possible jail time
but hunter seems to think he's Above the
Law now well I wonder where he got that
impression from maybe it was the
attempted sweetheart plea deal with
David Weiss or David Weiss allowing the
statute of limitations to pass or maybe
his daddy's doj running out the clock on
many of Hunter serious tax violations or
Hunter's ability to purchase massive
quantities of drugs and hire foreign
prostitutes with zero legal consequences
whatsoever or possibly it was all that
money that took in from America's
geopolitical foes like you know uh
Russia and China and Romania Etc uh
while his father was in a position of
great power and great influence all
while apparently not paying uh quite a
bit of money in taxes and on a lot of
income and that has to be resolved and
all of this for work that he has zero
experience in at a time where he was
admittedly addicted to drugs but while
the very liberal and biased and
political ized and weaponized Biden doj
drags its feet the Republican house is
taking action contrary to what Democrats
would have you believe the gop's
impeachment inquiry into Joe Biden is
very serious oversight committee
chairman James comr who will join us in
a moment is investigating legitimate
claims of corruption through closed door
hearings Financial forensics and other
inquiries Hunter meanwhile is attempting
to turn this into a political charade
with a public hearing but still comr is
more than willing willing to give Hunter
uh his circus but first that closed door
deposition would still be required as
ordered including by the way documents
handed over uh that's the subpoena
Hunter must comply of course this is all
part of Hunter's big new what they're
calling legal strategy to fight back
according to Politico today for years
has Hunter Biden faced a protracted
criminal probe he was told to cooperate
with prosecutors and wait quietly for
exoneration that strategy favored by
veteran Democrats failed so now he's
quote directly taking on his adversaries
with lawsuits and other legal threats
now some might call call this a campaign
of intimidation to others it might look
like desperation according to another
report White House staffers they are
extremely irritated with Hunter for not
clearing this new strategy with the
Biden White House and Democrats on
Capitol Hill are also unhappy with two
unnamed lawmakers calling Hunter's new
offensive strategy already risk no
reward this comes as one of Hunter's
friends is worried that the Democrats
are now eager to use the president's son
as a sacrificial lamb in this case the
big question tonight is Hunter willing
to tell the truth about his father or is
he willing to maybe take on the fall
himself and for republicans and other
logical people around the country well
this Scandal is not really about Hunter
about Hunter struggles with addiction
this is about the big guy in other words
the the real brand and that would be Joe
Biden who allegedly used his struggling
son to fill up the family coffers was
was Hunter for example selling access
and influence to that Biden brand so
that Jill and Joe Biden could afford
this you know beautiful beachfront um uh
estate in in Delaware live uh in luxury
on a senator's salary and according to
James comr PID 10 family members what
ends up to be tens of millions of
dollars middle class Joe and his wife
well they love to portray themselves as
living a middle class lifestyle but it
appears that image was not quite
accurate as Joe was buying expensive
Corvettes and again that beachfront
property and now let's see what the
bidens do are they ready to throw their
own son under the bus hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else